hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the
greatest match of the 19th century it's
paul charles murphy versus out of
anderson and this is game nine of their
match in my opinion the most notable
game and the one that you will
definitely want to show to all of your
friends in the bar in the library and it
is only 17 moves long but we're gonna
analyze it in quite a bit longer because
it's uh so rich and you know it could
have gone uh in any direction but the
direction that it took is the most
impressive one i would say and i
remember checking out this game when i
was very young when i only started you
know learning about the great players of
the past learning uh how to play chess
when i saw this game it was so
impressive i i you know tried to
learn it by heart as soon as possible
and try to employ this against my
opponents uh so it's really really
enjoyable uh let's check it out as
anderson is now down in the match it's
uh first the seven wins if you remember
draws not counting and if we disregard
the draws it's five wins morphy one win
for anderson so anderson needs to win
four games to to get back into the match
and that's not easy against an adversary
like morphy who as uh you've learned uh
by this uh
point in the saga as the match
progresses uh he only gets stronger and
stronger so without further ado let's
check it out morphe with the white
pieces opens with e4 and this game uh
especially anderson chooses a an opening
that he has not chosen uh so so far and
that is the sicilian defense he plays c5
and now how will morphe go about this
will he go knight to f3 will he try some
sort of a close sicilian no he opens the
position right away with d4 the smith
mora gambit we have c captures on d4 and
now uh not
going for c3 but rather knight to f3
also known as the morphe gambit um
probably due to this game uh and here uh
it's it's a very interesting position
because black can uh choose to defend
the pawn it's perfectly fine for black
to play e5 you cannot capture this pawn
and there's a very sad story when i like
i said when i started uh you know
learning chess i i entered a blitz
tournament and i had this position with
white and my opponent played e5 and i
thought you know he was um probably not
very good so i just grabbed the the pawn
and he played queen to a5 check and won
my knight and i was i was very sad about
this i was very very much embarrassed
and i i didn't know what was wrong with
me uh why why would i grab a pawn like
that and you know uh so
nowadays i i never just grab pawns uh
but okay after knight to f3 uh anderson
simply continues with knight to c6 he
gives back the pawn uh we have knight
capture sunday for now just uh
transposing into a normal open sicilian
and now e6 we have the timeout of the
variation now we have knights the b5 by
morphy now
trying to claim that the d6 square for
himself so d6 now the queen and the
bishop now guard this pawn uh and here
bishop to f4 by morphe adding a third
attacker to the d6 square and as our
good friend the uh uh or johannako
blumenthal said uh this is correctly
played compelling the advance of the e
pawn which leaves the queen's pawn weak
and unsupported uh so here uh the
advance of the e pawn is uh you know is
a must we have to play this so e5
chasing the bishop back morphy goes back
bishop to e3 and now comes f5 and again
it's it's a beautiful position that
already gives white sort of a winning
edge and you wouldn't expect this from a
position like this i mean
uh if you're only starting to play chess
you know your coach or teacher or your
friend who's a little bit better than
you uh will often uh say don't don't
play f5 don't play f6 don't touch this
spawn that should be protecting your
king at some point and here this is one
such case so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this incredible
move that morphe can play here while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on fighting this
uh well just uh just a gem in the
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is night one
to see three this is the move and this
is the move that yohanyakov uh lumenthal
uh characterizes as a fine conception
and now there's so much that black can
do here but none of it is really good
now just to give you an example uh if
you try something like a6 okay you want
to chase away this knight we're gonna
play knight to d5 we don't care about
this knight and after uh black captures
that now we play bishop to b6 as the
knight defends the bishop we attack the
queen and once the queen moves
regardless of
where the queen moves it just knight to
c7 check and we're going to pick up the
rook on a8 so
we're going to be better here there is a
really really complicated line that
black can use to defend this position
and that is knight to f6 but still uh it
only yields a lesser position bishop to
g5 now and still not not a good move for
black here it's very very difficult to
even approach this position because
there's always a bishop captures on f6
pretty much whatever black plays we're
going to play bishop captures on f6 for
example if a6 we're gonna play bishop
captures on f6 now you can't capture
with the queen because of knight to c7
check wins the rook so you have to
capture with the g pawn but now queen to
h5 check king to d7 now we capture on f5
with check and after the king moves now
we repeat queen h5 checking to d7 and
now knight to d5 and here you can see
that all of these squares are now taken
from the black king and the ones this
let's say knight is captured because if
you don't capture this you really have
nothing now we can simply play c3 i take
away these very nice squares from from
the black knight and next we're going to
play bishop to e2 to g4 and that's it
that's pretty much game or even g3 and
then bishop to h3 uh so you know black
will will be able to play this a little
bit longer but it's going to end badly
for him whatever he plays so after this
incredible knight 1 to c3 that all of
you found we have f4 by anderson this is
how he decides to play this but morphe
replied morphy's reply is the same he
plays knight to d5 now and the c7 square
is now his for the taking you don't have
a way of dealing with this even if
something like queen to a5 check it
doesn't really do anything just bishop
d2 and now you're attacking the queen
and also there's a double attack on the
c7 square so after this knight the d5
anderson says i know i know i have to
continue in in this style so f captures
an e3 and now knight beat the c7 with
check of course not this knight you want
this knight to remain centralized
controlling all of these squares so
knight beat the c7 with check and now
what do you do there are only two
squares for your king there's d7 and f7
if king the d7 morphe has made in one
queen to g for check is mate in one so
king the f7 has to be played and now
morphe uh has to decide whether to do
something about this pawn or just to go
very aggressively or even to capture the
rook uh if you
really let the engine crunch the numbers
here you'll get knight captures on a8 as
the best attempt from white
but
uh the only reason knight captures an a8
is best is because if you play the move
morphy played then it's possible to
defend this but with you know engine
like precision the point is after e
captures on f2 check king captures on f2
black can deliver queen h4 check we're
going to block this g3 now queen
captures an e4 attacking the rook and
now bishop the g2 and here
black doesn't have anything better than
let's say this queen to d4 check we're
going to trade here captures captures
and now let's say rook h to f1 uh
preparing to move the king deliver check
to the black king and the white is
definitely better here uh so this would
be uh objectively best but morphy goes
for a much much aesthetically more
pleasing line he plays queen to f3 check
uh and now anderson has to play with
with engine-like precision to defend
this he plays knight to f6 and now comes
bishop to c4 threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries and here as our good
friend johan lumenthal says the attack
is now irresistible
uh that's why i chose to make this the
title of the video uh now the attack
really is irresistible if you're playing
this game against morphe over the board
it's very very hard to imagine anyone
defending this although it is possible
to defend it i i will show you how uh
but just to give you an example okay if
you try to unpin let's say you play king
to g6 you do not want to remain on this
diagonal and the knights are covered
covering all of these squares so there's
no point in playing this if you go back
then of course you just run into knight
captures on f6 mate in one since it's
checked from the knight end from the
bishop there's no uh escaping a double
check
but just uh you know keep it fun if you
try escaping via king to g6 we just
deliver queen g3 check king h6 and now
queen captures an e3 with check king g6
now we're going to play knight captures
on e8 and it's just a
you know hopeless position for black
there's no playing this so anderson
chooses the only move that allows him to
stay in the game and that is knight to
d4 he allows the nasty discovery uh but
he has a way of dealing with it so
morphe of course goes for knight
captures on f6 delivering a check by the
bishop
and now we have d5 this move is key in
defending this attack because if you
play bishop to e6 uh it's just a very
you know a clean win with bishop
captures on e6 check knight captures and
now knight f uh to d5 with check opens
up a discovery from the queen king to g8
and not knight captures on e6 attacking
the queen and there's not much here you
can do if captures we're going to
capture with the king and i mean uh
you're down a piece your position is
hopeless there's no real way to enter
you know to bring your pieces into the
game uh this is completely winning for
morphe but uh like i said anderson plays
the only move that allows black to
not just you know uh
you know keep keep the quality but also
maybe play for something here and that
is d5 so what can morphe play here
morphe of course grabs this with the
bishop he delivers check and now is the
position that anderson i did not
evaluate uh
well with with uh engine like precision
he played king to g6 here and
unfortunately this was simply not to do
you have to play king to e7 and now as
complicated as it is it allows black to
defend here uh so what can we do here is
white we're just gonna show it uh okay
uh black is attacking our queen here
we're gonna play queen h5 and go for
this queen to f7 check but black doesn't
care black will capture the knight and
after queen f7 check king to d6 is
coming and now okay we're going to play
knight captures on a8 but now comes
knight captures on c2 with check king e2
and now
you don't even have to go for anything
here you can simply play queen to e7 and
now black has a lot to play for uh for
example rook uh we're gonna play rook h
to c1 uh go after this knight here and
now uh will black can simply play bishop
to g for check f3 trade queens here
captures captures and not knight to d4
with check it's a very very strong
knight so you don't want to just leave
it there and after the king moves let's
say bishop back to d7 and it's a you
know a very very complicated position
but black can defend the knights the c7
you want to bring the knight back into
the game but bishop to h6 now and it's
very very complicated but if anyone's
better here it should be black so
this was definitely possible in the
position and
it's only because of this line that
morphe's queen to f3 is not as precise
as the move we've shown when we when we
discussed queen to f3 so just grabbing
the rook uh was more precise but you
know morphy uh thought that if he
defends uh this position after queen to
f3 and bishop to c4 then i do not
deserve the win so here anderson played
king to g6 but now of course the attack
is um
just just you know
overwhelming for anderson uh morphy
plays queen to h5 check forces a capture
here king captures on f6 and now again a
beautiful position that i urge you to
you know just enjoy uh because this is
it just doesn't happen all that often
the the problem is uh now who you know
who amongst us would not play queen to
f7 check i mean it's such a it's a move
you play without even thinking about it
uh but if you do this then it's black
who's actually better because after king
to g5 there's no way to continue the
attack and well black has all of these
threats here that you you simply don't
want to face uh even if h4 king the h6
there's no way to continue the attack
here for white this is just incredible
if knight captures an a8 we can play
knight characters and c to check king d1
we're gonna capture on a1 and again i
mean
black black is just winning here there's
nothing white can do this bishop cannot
join the attack the knight can't join
the attack uh the rook cannot join the
attack and the queen can't even deliver
one check so uh it's just a very very
very sad position for morphe uh had he
played this but of course morphe did not
go for this uh after king captures an f6
queen to f7 although very very inviting
uh morphy says no
what about knight the e8 check this is a
move uh
uh our good friend johanna yacob logan
also comments on he says that knight the
e8 check seemingly a good move is only
in appearance because black can give up
the queen here and what do you do now if
queen captures then bishop to b for
check and black reclaims the queen so c3
we're gonna capture here on e8 and after
c captures on b4 just knife to c to
check even that is still in the position
we're going to capture the rook rook
captures on a1 and now he captures on f2
and i mean black is up a whole rook this
is completely winning for for anderson
uh so that's why
anderson probably went to g6 instead of
uh in the to the center of the board
when he had this uh this choice but
morphe plays something completely
different uh and after this king
captures an f6 he doesn't go for queen
to f7 he doesn't go for knight to e8
check he just plays f captures on e3 and
now morphe is threatening castles and
once this rook comes to the f file then
it's all over for the black king this is
probably what anderson missed uh and now
there's not nothing anderson can do he
played knight captures on c2 with check
morphe just played king to e2 and he was
in this position on move 17 yes we are
still only at move 17
that out of anderson resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
uh it's simply an incredible position
but uh you you could capture the rook
you could capture the knight i mean you
you could do stuff here you could play
g6 but none of it is enough we're going
to show a few lines for example if you
capture the knight we're just going to
play rook to f1 check and it's actually
a forced mating six rook to f1 check the
king is getting mated on the the b6
square so you have to go to e7 we're
gonna capture on e5 with czech king to
d7 bishop e6 check king to c6 now rook
to c1 with check and finally after king
to b6 we're going to deliver queen to b5
checkmate incredible stuff uh and
another thing after king to e2 you could
capture the c7 knight you don't have to
go after the rook but it's not uh you
know that doesn't really help you all
that much you just rook a to f1 check or
the other rook doesn't really matter
king the e7 and now rook to f7 with
check and black loses the queen king to
d6 we're going to capture on c7 king
captures and now even you know just for
good measure we're gonna trap the knight
as well and you know completely winning
for white there's nothing you can do
here so what's left here after king to
e2 okay anderson could try something
like g6 attack the queen maybe give
himself the g7 square for his king but
still just rook 8 to f1 check king g7
and now rook to f7 with check the bishop
nicely covers that and once you go here
then it's queen to these rook the d7 uh
checkmate blocking the queen's attack
towards the bishop and now the bishop
delivers check the king has nowhere to
go and there's nothing to block the
check with so uh simply an incredible
game and like i said there were many
games in the
uh 19th century that you know can be
considered uh great immortal amazing you
know and we've covered the most of them
uh you know uh the the nicest ones being
morphed opera game and anderson's uh
immortal game and the evergreen games uh
but in this game they they faced each
other and producing such a masterpiece
in a game between two of the greatest
players of that era uh
simply i i don't know i would say this
game definitely deserves to be in every
book you know and you know just just
everywhere so know this notice a game by
heart you don't have to know all of the
variations i mean it's 17 moves and
maybe some of the nicer ones but it will
get
a lot of your friends who are not maybe
uh enjoying chess yet interested in in
taking up chess
so yeah incredible game uh you know
great stuff for us great stuff for
morphe not so great for anderson because
now it's six wins morphe only one uh win
anderson and it's first the seven wins
so uh we'll see what happens later on
then later on in the match but uh hope
you guys enjoyed this one as this is uh
well this is my favorite game of the
match
and hope
i did a good job presenting it to you
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank anthea
in new orleans pablo mohan richard
yarnell michael sprague and david kimura
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
start of your week and i forgot to
mention uh not even our good friend
johan yacob until had anything bad to
say about this game uh see you soon guys